[Music]
welcome to this year's first view from
the top
we're extremely excited to kick off this
year's series with roz brewer the
chief operating officer and group
president for starbucks
raz was born and raised in detroit she
earned her bachelor's degree
in chemistry from spelman college and
began her first job
as a scientist at the kimberley clark
corporation she spent
more than two decades at the company
moving into business operations and
eventually becoming the president of one
of the company's
global divisions in 2006 raz was hired
as a regional vice president at walmart
six years later she became the president
and the ceo of sam's club
she was the first woman and the first
african-american to lead a division at
walmart
she then joined starbucks as chief
operating officer in 2017
and has been much celebrated for her
success there
even before helping to lead the company
through
the coveted pandemic fortune has named
raj to its list of 50 most powerful
women in business she's been featured in
an
exhibition on game changers at the
smithsonian
national museum of american history and
working mother magazine has named her to
the list of
top 10 most powerful moms which is
pretty awesome actually
two years ago raz delivered the
commencement address
at her alma mater spelman college and at
that time mary campbell the president of
the college
said those glass ceilings are real
but rise brewer has become an adept
glass cutter
she has walked the same road as many of
you and with
relentless determination so we're
looking forward to hearing more about
raz's story
and her achievements in today's
conversation with joy wong
nba21 raj thank you so much for joining
us it's really wonderful to have you
thank you for having me
ron we are so excited to finally have
you join us
thank you there's a lot of ground to
cover today we'll talk a lot
about how you lead large organizations
and dive deeper into your leadership
style
but first i would love to start from the
beginning and talk about some early
influences that you had in your life
sure let's do it so roz
many of us don't really start developing
our leadership
still uh styles until quite late in life
but from what i learned you seem to have
had a really strong voice from very
early on
in fact you were suspended from school
in third grade
what happened you know it amazes me what
people can find out about me but yes
that did happen
you know early on um you know some might
uh call me as a troublemaker but you
know being the youngest of five
i knew how to you know really
fight for that last uh piece of bread on
the table so the youngest of five
taught me how to be you know uh take
care of myself
but you know in third grade um i got
into
trouble because you know i'm sitting in
class and
uh you know the teacher is teaching math
and i had older siblings and
you know she's teaching this long way to
do this problem and
so i just thought i'd just get up and
help her out you know and just say no
there's a shortcut to this and so i keep
telling her until
the point where the next thing i knew
long story short my parents were at
school picking me up
uh you know because i was adamant about
taking that talk
and uh teaching the teacher and the
class
you know a shortcut on a math problem or
two so
um it's one way to get in trouble and um
you know
my parents you know i thought i was
really in trouble but you know i think
after a while i watched how many times i
would laugh at all the stuff i would do
as i was growing up
but uh i think that was my start
that's an amazing story and that's
actually funny because
here at the gsb there's this tradition
for doing shenanigans in class
and one of them is that you would get up
halfway and you would go to the white
board and teach um so it is
very funny to me how we're obviously
copying what you did in third grade
at the age of 26 exactly it's
it was crazy never grow old
um i'm curious so you said that your
parents kind of
find that funny um how did they react to
the incident
and and broadly how did your parents
shape your values
sure well i think it was eventually they
thought it was funny because initially
you know my parents
were so adamant about education and you
know i grew up in a family in a
household where kids were
to be seen and not heard you know and so
we were you know
always you know shut it off to do the
things that we were right and it was
very strict household
a lot of that came from my parents did
not have the opportunity to go to
college
and quite honestly neither finished high
school
and so for them to have five children
and i'm the youngest of five
acting out in school was totally
unacceptable
because they knew you know it's a fine
thread between you know getting kicked
out of school once
and what can happen to you i think what
made it a little funny was because i
really wasn't
acting out i was just trying to get my
voice heard right
and so i think they began to see that
you know
i want to use my voice and you know
maybe i had raised my hand and she
didn't pay attention to me
you know and so they started really
understanding that the dynamics
in some of the classrooms you know and
so it it turned into a different story
but quite honestly that would have been
disciplinary and
action by my parents because they were
so strict about
education they didn't want us to miss a
thing and
so um it was the beginning of us you
know really having
um conversations about what does it take
to be excellent
and what's the expectation of you and
they would constantly raise the bar for
everything in our lives and so
for all five of us to go to college on
the backs of two parents who
you know never really were able to do
that and worked in the automotive
automotive industry was really um heroic
on my parents part
yeah and it sounds like they really
instilled this this confidence in you
and a drive and to uh to to speak up and
and have a strong voice
and with that confidence you then decide
um to
leave home and then attended spelman
college
and you have often talked about spelman
as a very defining experience for you
so i'm curious what were some lessons
that you learned there
that stayed with you until today sure so
you know spelman's a very small school
private
um black all-women's college in the
south
i grew up in detroit and um first of all
i had never
experienced you know the the southern
life um
and it was vastly different for me i was
the only
being the youngest of five i'm the only
one that went to went away to school
everyone else is wonderful schools in
the state of michigan i wanted to move
away and i did
but spelman when i got there i realized
that it was
my new home because in that environment
first of all i love that it was a
liberal arts
institution because i got a chance to
really dive into critical thinking
and they were getting all into your head
about things that i'd never really
thought about
but then also too is such a nurturing
environment to have a
you know first name basis with your
professors
and um and the all the entire faculty
it was very special to me and to be in
the environment of
people who women who look like me but
came from all different walks of life
i thought i was in a knew that i was in
a very unique situation
and so going to an hbcu is a very
deliberate decision
you're deciding to go into an
environment that's that's pretty unique
especially all women
but i remember a couple of experiences
that made me realize how special spelman
was so
by my senior year my dad had been
diagnosed with cancer
and spring break of my senior year i'm
studying for the gmat
trying to finish my major in chemistry
minor in
uh math all at the same time when i get
the call that i need to get home because
this looks like
you know my father was um moving was
passing on
and so this was six weeks before
graduation
and um you know all of a sudden i get my
organic teacher changing all of my
um test dates for me so that i can test
when i get back
uh the school chaplain was in my dorm
room like within 10 minutes after
getting the call
and you know everyone was just rallying
around me just trying to give me the
strength to get home
get my dad buried get back to school
take the gmat
and graduate in six weeks and um
you know i don't know that that would
have happened for me at any other
institution
and so it is something to have that kind
of feeling and closeness that i will
absolutely never forget my experience at
spelman because i felt like people saw
me for me
and um not as you know another number in
the school
so it's it's a special place a very
special place
it sounded like a really hard experience
to go through and i'm so glad that the
school was fully supportive review
um you did talk a lot about it being
being a strong community
um so during my research i actually came
across something on social media
if you could see on the screen you
probably remember this yes
yeah oh wow yeah that was
october 2nd 2018 the day it was
announced that i was
the new chief operating officer for
starbucks
yeah so this this was an amazing time um
all over the country actually all over
the world
um i had um my sorority sisters actually
i'm an alpha kappa alpha
uh uh just like uh kamala
uh harris and so uh you know they
rallied around me and every
drive-through or store they went into
they ordered their drink and put my name
on it and it was
it was overwhelming when i saw i didn't
see this because i was
involved in the press releases that
morning and i got back to my hotel room
i was in seattle
and i turned on social you know i was
starting to look at my social media feed
and i saw all these cups and i just
absolutely lost it i mean i remember i
slipped off the bed onto the floor and i
was just like oh my god
did they really do this and it was just
a reminder that there's no other
place um in the world that you can
feel like you know someone accepts you
for you
and it was you know my sorority my
college
um and uh it was a truly heartfelt
moment
but it was amazing it was really great
yeah it's so incredible to see that the
relationship that you had
we're still so strong it was 20 odd
years later
um and also just inspiring to to see
that you have such an impact on your
community
well it was it was it was something else
it was amazing now rod
um your influence obviously at impact
extends
way beyond spelman into the many
organizations that you've been part of
and as a leader what you like to say is
that you like to lead both with your
head and with your heart
yeah so i thought we should start with
the first piece leading with the head
now you've been in the retail industry
for more than 10 years now
and um you were quite the visionary
during a lot of time
for example when you were at sam's club
you invested a lot of effort into
curbside pickup and e-commerce efforts
um which was quite ahead of many of the
the offline retailer peers
um and still a really critical piece of
the the strategy for walmart today
um so i'm curious now you're leading
starbucks you're on the board of amazon
what are some big bets that you're
making on the future of retail
sure so you know it's interesting
because some of that work i'm bringing
forward with me
to starbucks but i will say that joining
starbucks starbucks had a fantastic
digital flywheel once i joined there
and their loyalty program was very
strong but
as you know any business leader will
tell you is that every day
it's about trade-offs can we continue to
invest
in all of the technology that we need to
have
and still do everything else we need to
do to innovate at the company
and so myself along with many others
because there's some
extremely bright brilliant talent at
starbucks i am so fortunate to have the
kind of partners that i have there
but we created uh together in innovation
lab
and in that innovation lab we began to
think about how do we change
the engine of making coffee at starbucks
and so we have baristas that
love the beautiful craft of making a
wonderful latte
and so they want to be seen doing that
um but actually you know
we're pretty popular right now and so in
the morning you know we have stores that
will do
you know uh you know some astronomical
number
of coffee cups per minute right and so
we
began to look at a new engine at
starbucks and so we introduced
a new model where it's a pickup only
store where everything is digital
we flip the kitchen to the back and
we've opened up several of those we have
three or four of those in our unit but
we just recently announced we're gonna
add more of these pickup units to our
our
our fleet uh so the technology uh goes
on and on
with with starbucks so it starts also
with the stores and then also too
relieving our baristas of having to do
any kind of manual work
like manual scheduling so all scheduling
is automated
centralized planning and replenishment
is underway
everything that we're doing from
optimizing the drive-through window
and what's so interesting is that going
into this cobot experience in life where
we're trying to create social distancing
everything that we had in our innovation
pipeline we've been able to bring it
forward
pretty quickly so that's been part of
our recovery plan we had
innovation plans three to five years out
we're now
executing that on an a by 18 months
we'll have all of that innovation
out in the field and so it's pretty
exciting it's around beverage innovation
the store innovation and then what we
continue to do with the digital flywheel
so
um you know i've um i'm very grateful
for the work
and the things that i learned at walmart
because i'm actually bringing that
forward
at starbucks and it's exciting to have
you know be with a coffee company that's
so
digitally you know sound as we are so
it's pretty exciting
and one thing that you mentioned that
will probably continue after the
pandemic
is this trend towards everything going
more virtual and digital
right and you talk about changing store
formats into pickup only
um it seems like a very particular
problem to starbucks because
the company has always prided itself on
being a third place and a place where
people will come together
and and relax and have a great
conversation um
so how do you think about creating and
maintaining that connection in that
community
in a virtual world yes and you know that
is one of the things that we put
you know we look at our work as what are
the most significant
problems we can solve and that is one of
them because
you know that's what we admire about our
mission and values is that third place
but when you approach a starbucks and
you see the
familiarity of your barista that you
love
and that you can say hello how are you
jessica and you remember your barista
your barista remembers the customer
it starts right there and that's rather
you're handing something through the
drive-through window or you're going out
to curbside
and we right now i'll tell you our
customer connection scores
are higher than they were pre-coveted
and that's pretty exciting
to see that you know first of all we
know that
people are starving for connection again
and they're starving for something that
they're familiar with so that
you know their customized beverage is
something that they look forward to and
when starbucks opened back up they were
like oh my gosh
okay there's something that's normal
here and i can see my barista and
we never underestimate that so the
things that we're doing is
we're just trying our best to free up
our baristas time so that they can give
eye contact and look the customer
squarely in the face
and you know i i get amazed and i tour a
ton of stores i'm still touring stores
even through covet
i'm just doing my own driving um to
stores by myself in the in the vehicle
in my own car
and just going to stores and walking in
and spending time at a distance
uh with the baristas because they want
to see us and then i hear the
conversations between the customers and
the baristas
and the excitement of them reconnecting
it's amazing to me and it
and it helps me understand that um some
of this will be temporary
but what they really want is that human
connection and we can still provide that
even if we're going to some of our
convenience my
models so we're pretty excited about
that and our customers are giving us
great feedback right now
yeah as a person who's going through her
second zoom quarter i
i totally advertise with that yeah it's
it's been it's been really wonderful to
see
so and roz you are a bit different from
a lot of our
guests uh for view from the top in that
many of them are ceos but
you are a true operator and you've led
massive
organizations like like sam's club and
and uh starbucks
um and i think you have this amazing
ability to to see the big picture
but also to really get into the weeds um
an example was that when you joined
starbucks um the it was actually kind of
a low point for the business and sales
wasn't doing well
and you came in and quickly discovered
some operational issues that really
moved the needle
um one of them was an insight that store
traffic
was too slow at around two o'clock in
the afternoon
that's right yeah i and i bet there
could have been maybe 50 hundreds of
issues that you could have
looked into um so how are you able to
hone in so quickly at such a micro level
sure so you know one of the things on
being at walmart
is that you know you spent you we we got
a chance to spend a lot of time in
stores and after a while
i can almost walk in a store and get a
feel
for the operations of the store one
prime example is if i walk in a store
i can tell if the employees are not
proud of their unit they'll immediately
look down at their feet so i know
they're either not proud of the
operation
they recognize who i am and i'm about to
hear the story
so what i try to do when i walk in these
units is to kind of diffuse that to say
look i'm here to help
i'm not here to reprimand so you know
i've thrown trucks
at walmart which means unloaded midnight
you know i've done that
and you know i wouldn't enjoy getting
behind the bar i don't make the best
latte but i try my best to do
latte art as best i can looks a little
weird sometimes
but you know i try to meet them where
they are because
i feel so responsible that there's
probably something that we did
at the home office that's creating a bad
outcome at the store
so that's that's part of it but i've
also um
you know having a background in
chemistry i'm a little bit of an
analytics so you can kind of watch
operation and see what's flowing and not
flowing and
and then match it with numbers and data
and analytics and pretty come out
pretty much come out with your solution
so um you know understanding that we
were maxing out in the morning but then
tons of opportunity in the afternoon it
was a chance for us to say what is
what's the menu in the afternoon
what's a customer looking for in the
afternoon who's in the store in the
afternoon
what's competition doing in the
afternoon and then you know we were able
to adjust
um and offer something different in the
afternoon day part and begin to
grow the business that way so we dug
ourselves out of a pretty deep hole
um back at that time and you know it's
still
pre-covet we were having some of the
most fantastic results
and as you saw in our prior earnings
we're returning uh to recovery
um in short order so um you know it pays
off to be
um an operator i will tell you i say
it's like the ultimate bob and weave
i've got to go
high and create strategy and multi-year
you know straight the
create the vision create a road map
give people something to aspire to
create hope but then i've got to be able
to kind of live in their shoes to know
that
when i make these changes and i suggest
big major growth initiatives
i have to understand what is it going to
take to get this team to follow me
and i'm really glad that i had some of
the small
jobs that i have but i realize the
reason why i've had some of these small
jobs too
is because uh quite honestly you know
there were times in my career where i
was given the
you know the unfortunate work to do and
i always had to do
some of the toughest dirtiest jobs um
and i had to do those so but it
gave me a chance to learn and i try and
put it to work every day
and look at it as a blessing that i got
some of the smaller jobs the unfortunate
positions
yeah it's amazing to hear that you took
that experience
and didn't complain about it but but
rather turn it into a lot of empathy
than than now for your
employees um and it it's
interesting to see how you know it's a
combination of both
um the analytics and then also just
feeling the story and seeing the people
but again starbucks has thousands of
stores and 300 000
employees so when it's at that scale
how do you make sure you're successful
in driving execution
and then uh perhaps equally importantly
at motivating those people so so they're
aligned around the same goal
sure so it is all about your talent
right and so
having um the ability to identify great
talent
um and it's not just individual talent
it's also looking at what's the dynamics
of your team how do you get that team
to move like an or like an orchestra and
that's what i always say is that i feel
like i'm the conductor
of the orchestra and i want it to have
its best performance so i can't
just select one or two good talents i've
got to figure out
how are these people going to work
together um you know
prime examples right now the
executive vice president for u.s
operations that reports to me
she is a fantastic people leader she can
motivate
like something i've never seen and when
you've got that large number of stores
you need someone like that and she's not
one that i'm gonna press about
strategy i'm not gonna press about her
spending because i trust she'll do that
very well but more than anything i know
she'll motivate
that barista that's on the front line
and that's so important so it really
begins with the talent that you select
and how you put those pieces together
and then how do you build the trusting
relationships because they've gotta know
that i have their back every day i
instill that in them i stand up for them
i fight for them
and so then i think when i do create
that visionary message they trust that
i'm going to get them
over the finish line right and they know
i'm not going to leave them on the
sideline they know i'm not going to
blame them they know i'm going to dig
into the details with them
and so we begin to work together because
i i do believe in
still rolling my sleeves up um it takes
that you cannot
in in retail today if you're not willing
to roll your sleeves up
um get ready for some pretty mundane
numbers because it takes you really
getting into the trenches
to get these companies to grow and
that's what it takes right now
and speaking of motivating people i
think this is a great segue
into the second piece of your leadership
which is leading with the heart
and as an asian woman i i could
sometimes get a little
tired of questions around diversity and
equality
but at the same time i do recognize the
value of sharing my own experience in
the hope that it sparks conversation
so in that spirit i would love to
revisit a moment that was
particularly difficult for you early in
the days
and it was only a few months after you
had took over the starbucks america's
business
two black men rashaan nelson and dante
robinson
were wonderfully arrested in the
starbucks store in philadelphia
now i think many of us knew the facts of
what happened
later but could you take us back to that
moment
you just heard about the incident you
got on a flight you're on your way to
philadelphia
what was going through your mind sure
so you know when i got the news um
and and it was interesting the way i
began to pick up the news
and um the news was really hot on black
social media
and it hadn't quite hit anywhere else so
i'm hearing it
and i'm letting you know other people in
the company know and it's kind of
catching up with us that we got a
problem in philadelphia
once we realized just how bad it was um
we did
i did take off to philadelphia and meet
some of my
partners there the first thing that
really startled me was that i was begin
beginning to get the feed
on the two gentlemen and i could see
what they look like so i knew right away
so first of all
it was two people arrested it wasn't we
didn't know that they were
african-american males
it quickly became african-american males
and then when i saw them
the first thing i thought about is um
wow you know this this is not going to
be good
in addition to they look so familiar to
me right because
um they're everything that i've seen in
my communities right
and by the way i have a son i haven't my
son was that exact same
age and so i looked at what happened and
thought
this could happen to my son any day
of the week and i was actually terrified
because those two gentlemen went to jail
that night
and they stayed there overnight just for
having walked into a starbucks
and there's something wrong with that
there's something wrong and i knew right
away there was something wrong
and um we got into philadelphia um
created a war room
and began to work on this situation and
the first thing was to make sure that
these two gentlemen returned safely to
their home
and uh and we were engaged in in
um in in that work um and then began to
tell the story
and to admit that uh starbucks did
something wrong here
and you know our policies failed us our
leadership failed us
um this happened under i felt like it
happened under my watch
um i was running i'm running u.s
operations part of our responsibility
and these two gentlemen the police were
called after 10 minutes of being in our
stores
now um that's not what we do at
starbucks
and so i knew and then i looked at the
young woman who was running that store
and like i
mentioned before leadership um is you
know
all about the talent that you selected
she's a fine talent
but for her to work at a store at 18th
and spruce
in philadelphia and she's a young new
leader
we set her up for um failure and then
the whole system falls down falls apart
and the interpretation of policies was
taken for granted
um we had work to do and the other thing
is that
we had not had the realization that
what's happening outside a starbucks
store
has begun to come inside the store so
homelessness and all those things that
are happening in our communities
but our policies say you know allow
people to
have a beverage sit down stay for a
while if they're not ordering after
about 45 minutes
you know maybe encourage them to have a
beverage but you know now
people come into our stores for respite
right and for warmth
and but our policies were based on
something years ago when that's not what
a starbucks store was
you know equipped to do and our leaders
weren't trained to how do you handle
anyone coming in and outside the store
so it could be misinterpreted
and it was so we admitted our faults but
we got around this issue we knew we
needed to train on anti-bias training
there are some biases that were
likely involved in this and we got after
it and we continue to get after it
daily with training and development and
leadership at the right time right
person in the right role
all of those things really matter in
terms of how you want to manage but it
was frightening
because i knew at any moment that could
have been my son and
quite frankly i got a call from my son
and uh he's living in new york and he
said mom you know this thing is
this is bad and you have got to fix it
and i'm
and you've got to do this this is all
this is everything you need to do right
now and when you hear your son
talking to you i picked up fear in his
voice
because i think he was saying mom fight
for me because that's me
i felt that and i fought like
hell for him and for dante and rashawn
that this will never happen again
and like you're saying in that moment
yes you're the ceo but
you're also a mother and then you are
part of the community
how did you think about balancing having
your own voice versus
quote-unquote being the voice of the
company right right so
you know i think um you know timing is
everything i think the company was open
to my influence on this situation
i think they clearly recognize that i'm
going to take care of the brand and do
the right thing for the company
um but we all have to recognize when the
company
um has not done its best work and
um that was a very honest moment for all
of us and so i think there was
immediate um you know growing trust for
me they were getting to know me
but they knew that i was going to take
care of the company as well as take care
of this situation because i felt like if
i could influence starbucks
and you know the visibility of this
brand could we absolutely
influence other companies so all the
training that we developed we did it
open source
so if any company calls us and said how
did you do that you know you closed your
stores where
who did your training we developed our
training here take it
and it was expensive and we gave it to
any company or anyone who called us and
said look we'll teach you how to do this
um no charge because this is a problem
not only for starbucks it's a problem in
our society right now of making judgment
of people
um you know prematurely and it has to
stop
and you know eight police officers
called for
two gentlemen sitting in a store is
unacceptable
and we're fortunate that that's all that
happened to those two gentlemen that
they had to stay overnight
very fortunate because we've since then
right learned some other things
that could be terrible yeah
yeah and it's good to know that in that
moment it seems like those two things
really aligned
and yet it was still very a very
emotional moment for you right
you talking about fear and worry and and
it just sounded
really overwhelming so how how do you
take care of yourself
in moments like that yeah well i'll be
honest with you
for that period of time where we were in
philadelphia the media was
pretty hot um i took on a lot of the
local media
the other good thing is that throughout
my career i've gotten to know
pretty much most of the mayors across
the united states i make it my business
to know them because i feel like i'm
going to need to have a conversation
with them
either i'm buying real estate in their
city or investing or something so
um i used my rolodex like i never
like i've never have and i called in you
know a lot of help for people to teach
me how to have these
conversations so i tried to keep my fear
down and turn it into energy it was
sleepless i mean we didn't go to bed
several days i remember one day we had
to go over to the courthouse
and i'd run out of clothes and so i had
on
a pajama shirt with my suit jacket over
it and so
i kept pulling my jacket to cover up the
little teddy bear on my shirt because i
still had on my pjs up under there
because i couldn't get out of the hotel
because people were
wanted to touch and feel it so i put it
that way
and so you it's amazing what you'll do
when you know you've got a little bit of
fear and anxiety
but you know you've got you've got work
to do you just
buckle down and do what you have to do
and wearing a pajama shirt up under your
you know your suit is not the worst
thing that'll ever happen to you
so you just have to keep your head on
straight it was hard to focus
but i knew that we were doing the right
thing and i knew that we were
living in a historical moment and we had
a chance to either do this very right or
do it very wrong
but everything i had learned in my life
came to bear
in that situation my son's face these
two young men who were trying to start a
new business they were there to have a
conversation about starting a new
company
my new company that i was falling in
love with i didn't want them to fall on
the ground
you know the lovely young woman who we
had hired to work in this store what's
going to happen to her so everything was
coming together
and so this whole concept of head and
heart you know that is the leadership
model that makes you most successful in
these heated moments because you can't
have if i went through this thing just
with my head
i would have made a whole lot of
different decisions you know it probably
would have been much more abrasive
um and but i was able to keep my head on
straight
thank you so much for sharing that
really personal and emotional side with
us
and it's inspiring to see that that
actually helps you become more
effective as a leader and not um to your
detriment
um as a senior leader you're never
afraid to say
what is right um but for some of us
and for me at least um as we're a bit
earlier in our career it could sometimes
feel
very risky uh or and daunting to speak
up
if we don't feel like we have sufficient
credibility or
seniority so i'm curious how has your
voice evolved as you became
more senior sure so what you just
described that was me
early on in my career um you know i i
actually felt like my voice didn't
really matter because i was overlooked
so much i was like well
they don't care to hear what i have to
say so i can go to a meeting unprepared
or
you know because they're not ever going
to call on me it doesn't matter you know
and um you know that's pretty
frustrating after a while i mean you
know i was doing a job on my own self
with that mentality
but then um and and then my next
you know the next part of me after that
was
trying to find my place and use my voice
and i then began to be too much like the
company person i began to dress like all
the men
at work and all of that crazy stuff and
it was ugly
apparel i hated it but i did it anyway
and i was sick when i was driving home
like who is this
and then i just you know and i'd get
home and my family would be like
okay why are you talking like that and
so then after a while it was so
stressful
that i just said i just have to figure
out how to bring my whole self to work
so
um you know i have two children i have a
son and a daughter my daughter is 17.
well early on you know my daughter
wanted to swim she's african-american
so like every other black family you
have to get your daughter's hair braided
that's just the whole deal if they're
going to swim you got to get the air
braided so one day i'm leaving work
they're like why are you leaving early i
was like i gotta go get my daughter's
hair braided swim class is starting
like why are you braiding her hair i was
like because if i don't
i i'm gonna have to deal with this hair
on her head and so
i had to explain cornrows to people i
work with
and after a while i just decided it was
so stressful trying to hide i could have
said oh i'm leaving the office for a
doctor's meeting
a doctor's appointment i was like no i
gotta go get cornrows done so i was you
know
let me tell you what that's like i to
sit here for eight hours you know in
in the salon so um but once i started
doing that i felt so much better the
stress was so
high of me trying to be two different
people i could not
bear it anymore i was not myself and so
i just
reconciled that i've got to bring my
whole self to work
and the more that i was like who i am in
my day in my personal life
at work actually work took off because i
think people got to know me better
and they knew how they could see me for
me
and there was no shell they had to peel
off so it was
uncomfortable for my peers my boss
everyone else
but once i started once i decided what
do i have to lose
you know um so it was so much better but
the other thing i i look back on and
this is what i tell when i
have a new hire that's uh straight from
school is that
we know why we intentionally hired you
you know this isn't a numbers game
but if i hire an asian woman that's
because i want
an asian woman's voice at the table so
if you come and don't use your voice
i feel like i got a bad investment here
so i always tell folks
understand why you're here don't be
bashful about it let's be clear
i need an asian woman's voice at the
table so that's why here this isn't
anything about
you know um i need you know they hit a
number a diversity number
and so sometimes when i see people
sitting back in their seat and not
engaging in the conversation i will call
on them
and say what do you think and they hate
it
but after a while and then i don't you
know i just say okay good idea
move on you know but i keep picking on
them until they feel because first of
all you gotta hear yourself talk
and once you hear yourself talk you're
like okay i can talk i mean you know
it's just that simple
and then when people nod people will nod
at your idea
then you're gonna find somebody that's
gonna use your idea once you say it
they're just going to say a little
different
and then after a while it just it
becomes a pr a process
but don't sit silent in the room and i
try my best whenever i see that i always
call that person out
and try to give them a platform and i'll
endorse what they say
i'll help them with their viewpoint i
see that they're struggling
because it absolutely it still takes
that but don't be silent in the room
even if you think you're going to make a
mistake that's better than sitting there
quiet because you begin to suffocate to
be honest with you you suffocate your
opinion yourself
it'll change your self-esteem so just
get it out there
and feel like you have value and i think
it's so important
that is amazing advice and ros
you've been advocating for equality for
many years but it a lot of times it just
seems like things haven't changed as
much as we
would have loved them to and i know this
year has been particularly difficult for
a lot of us
as we continue to witness racism and
injustice and at times it could feel
very overwhelming and disheartening
um i'm curious if you see any hope in
the moment
and and what do you think we can all
collectively do
to use this moment to move forward
together
yeah you know um i'll be uh really frank
with you
you know there's been some days where
i've had to really pull myself
up um to say and do the right thing you
know because i'm human too
you know i'm a mom you know the ahmad
aubry thing
really struck me hard that one stuck
with me
george floyd murder stuck with me um
you know i have it's so interesting i
have all nephews and only one niece and
so all these black males young black
males are around me
and so i remain nervous and scared for
them right now
and you know wondering what more that i
can do but
i pull myself up knowing that if i stay
steadfast
to set the example engage as many people
as i can
in conversations and use myself as an
example to teach and educate
maybe i do have a way to begin to change
these narratives and the views of people
the other thing i think that that i've
been really focusing on is getting
people to vote
and vote in the vote in every election i
don't care if it looks like a school
superintendent and you're you know
just go vote you know um and so i'm i've
been a
pretty big advocate for that um it's the
best way we can change and have our
voice heard
is to vote i think also too i'm an
optimist
and i think that there is something
about a pandemic
happening during the time of social
unrest
during the time of some of the most
environmental ish biggest environmental
issues
ever between in one week we had fires
flooding and storms all in one week
across two different parts of the
country
and then the outcome of this is to see
the inequities
of who gets help and who doesn't get
help
and so you know when you see about you
know you see things like
what's happening with covet and you
can't say well why is that happening
well why are african-americans and
latinos
why are they more exposed well it's
because of housing and living conditions
years ago asthma is something
that is environmental right and so what
was their housing situation like
where are there opportunities for
medicine
and by the way where's the education
system so what this is doing right now
this very moment that we're in it
is unveiling the weaknesses in our
country
like never before so while we all regret
it
i personally regret it it is now pulling
the covers off of
so many embedded issues that we have to
face because these things will happen
again
but hopefully we'll never go into a
pandemic
while our communities are in such social
unrest so um you know
put in positions where health care is
not available to them
hopefully we'll begin to do things
different because right now
we have a laser beam on the real ills of
our country right now and we should be
paying attention to those
yeah that's very true and i hope more
people would not just pay attention but
also be part of it
and share the burden exactly yeah and i
i can't wait
i hope soon enough we'll be so obsessed
about talking about equality
the same way that we're obsessed with uh
quarterly earnings today
exactly exactly that's so true you're
right about that
ross i time just flew um i'm at the
we're at the end of the interview it's
truly been a pleasure um
we did select some students for a q a
session
so we'll turn to those student questions
right now awesome
that's great
i think we see the first student on the
screen do you mind introducing yourself
before the question
hi roz hi joy um i'm marcia austin i'm
an nba one here at the gsb
great and so my question for you is this
what was the most pivotal point in your
career that you
think was the point that led you to the
c-suite
uh i think
probably the most pivotal moment that
led me to the c-suite was
when i left kimberly clark after uh 22
years of being in the cpg
industry i was group president of
global manufacturing and operations and
i left there
to take a role at walmart as a vice
president
a regional leader out in the field
running stores
and i knew either i was crazy or i was
determined to do something great
at the time walmart didn't have the best
reputation at that time
and um i knew i was walking into either
a gold mine
or you know something else but it was an
opportunity for me to really step up i
really wanted to
impact the most people that i possibly
could and walmart has 2.2 million
employees and i said you know what roz
forget about you know i really wasn't
thinking about this c-suite i was
thinking about
impact but now i realize um you know
impact comes with scale and growth and i
knew
um as soon as i got in there i was
promoted for four months after i
came in as a vp i was made senior vice
president and then within
a year executive vice president so um
you know but
again i wasn't in pursuit of the ceo job
i actually
you know when i got the call for the
sam's role after being with the company
for
five to six years um you know
i knew then i was like oh wow this must
be a big opportunity you know so it
wasn't like i was looking for that but i
think that moment where i said i'm
willing to throw away
a title a comfortable job to go to
an environment um i knew i had something
in me that i was trying to satisfy and
it was impact
and so i think that that gets you to
some of the higher levels when you
pull yourself out of trying to get a
title and put yourself
into a big problem to solve
yeah that really resonated and i think
here
in the silicon valley we probably
sometimes bias towards like founding our
own thing and creating impact that way
yeah two million employees um that's
that's like that's impact for you that's
impact
that's right uh we're going to take a
question
yeah so hi hi good morning from germany
yeah so my name is violeta i'm in
stanford lead program it's my first
month and i'm
very very happy and excited that i have
the opportunity to ask you a question
on one side you have mentioned about
covid speeding up your pipeline your
innovation lab
projects but i'm interested about
now about the current situation so so my
question is
how do you manage to operate
successfully under discovery 19
situation
to maintain a durable and growing
business
yes um i love this question because you
know we're trying to
understand what is gonna you know remain
permanent what you know um i don't
really enjoy the term new normal
but there's gonna be some permanence out
of this and then there are some things
that's very temporary and trying to
separate the two of those um is where
the difficulty
uh comes into play but i will tell you
um you know one of the things we're
learning about covet
is you know how important it is to keep
your business
sharp you know we've got a pretty clean
balance sheet so we went into this
um in a strong financial position but
not knowing whatever
you know what could happen to your
business you know it just reminds us all
to run this thing pretty sharp
because you know there are some
companies that are not going to make it
and that are relying on a lot of help
from um
from the government so it's it's just a
reminder
you know going through this covet
experience in terms of how important it
is to stay sharp
um i also will say that who would have
ever thought that we would have a life
living in technology like we're doing
right now
and how can we you know remain humanized
you know
like the question that i got earlier um
you know about
you know what are those things how you
know do we keep the starbucks brand
fresh
but i'll tell you is that if you've not
learned empathy through this
instance you shouldn't be a leader right
now
because people this is very difficult we
have
young mothers who are on zoom calls all
day
while they're trying to teach a four or
five year old
how to get themselves through a zoom
call and get their lessons done
um i i i'm telling you i feel so
blessed that my kids are older because
i'd have to throw in the towel
and we cannot afford to have women not
in the workplace
that is just not acceptable it can't
happen we've got to think of other
solutions
one of the things i've done in my
organization is that we have no meetings
before 9am
because you need to get the kids settled
and get them at least in front of the
laptop and pack a lunch and prop them up
in front of that screen that's the
reality
and then we have something on fridays
called quick
connect fridays and the only thing
you're allowed to do on a friday is call
someone and say hello
you can't have any business any serious
business meetings
um and it's for you to reflect on the
week
recognize people give people recognition
and call and check on somebody and so we
call it quick connect fridays
and no meetings monday through friday
before 9 a.m
and that's one of the things that covet
has taught us is to meet
your employee base where they are and
it's
important now and it's going to be
important for a while
i think he's just waiting for the third
student to come on the screen
hi roz uh my name's steve soma i'm also
a member of the stanford lead program
and my question i think you kind of
touched on this a little bit but maybe
you could expand on it was
how does the shift to remote work uh
influence your leadership style if at
all
yeah so um what i just mentioned is is
part of it but i think the other part
is i'm finding as a leader that i have
to be very intentional
um because you know when you've got
someone engaged in a camera
you know it's not like you're going to
lean over and have a casual discussion
and you know create the sidebars and
sidebar
conversations can be very rich right
because you kind of vibe off of each
other
so one of the things that i worry about
a bit is that what about our future
innovation because innovation happens
when
you know brains collide and
conversations happen
so we've been you know using some unique
software for that
to help us as software called nero that
you probably are familiar with
or um you know just um you know i was
able to
go over to the home office this week in
seattle and spend some time in our
innovation lab just to connect with
people to say i see the work you're
doing
i you know love what you're doing and to
keep on so i'm spending a lot of my time
um just making sure that i have these
connection points with
individuals and making sure that
innovation keeps going that's one of the
things i worry about is that
um you know refilling that pipeline
of of innovation right now
rose i love that even though you were
talking about innovation but
you are still fundamentally talking
about people and meeting them where they
are
and and um making sure that they could
have a voice
um i have one last question for you
before we wrap it up
um we'll be asking this question to all
the speakers that join us this year
what principles do you rely on when
you're facing the toughest moments as a
leader
so in my toughest moments um first of
all
i rely on high integrity
and so first and foremost i want to make
sure
that i am doing the right thing um by
the situation in my
integrity nor the integrity of the
company is going to be impaired
so i would have to say high integrity is
the first thing
the second thing that i rely on is
trust i want to make sure that each and
every day i'm building
trust people want to know that they work
for somebody that cares about them
and wants to um and that they can be
dependent upon
so i i rely on on trust and trusting
relationships
and then lastly i think what i depend on
and this is the operator in me
is just doing what i say i'm going to do
and that's not always easy you know i
have competing objectives sometimes
i have a very tough calendar
um i'm a director of one of the largest
companies in the world that
you know is a fantastic company amazon
so i have to make sure
that i can deliver on what i say i can
do because it's part of who i want to be
known for i want people to
um feel like they can trust me and that
they can count on me
so that that really matters to me quite
a bit
thank you for sharing that roz i we
learned
so much from this conversation about
managing massive organizations about
motivating people
making tough decisions but but i think
above all
about how we should and can show up as
ourselves and and
with our values and speak up when when
uh
something's not right yes so
yeah i thank you again for joining us
and uh thank you for making
our world a more equitable and well
caffeinated place
yeah that's awesome well thank you so
much i've so enjoyed this and
you know to the students and the faculty
there um
keep doing great things i mean the most
important thing we can do is just get
into the minds of
you know young people make them feel
valued show them the ropes and the road
maps
and the future and the vision of what
can be and
we'll all get through this um we'll all
be better for it
so but thank you for having me thank you
ross it's been an honor